이 바닥에 있는 타일이
외벽 타일이에요 외벽 그 건물 외벽에
썼던 타일을 바닥재
타일로 재사용을
했더라고요네 여기
파란 타일이 외벽에 썼던 타일이에요
그래서 이게
근데 이렇게 바꾸는데
200만원이 채 안 들었거든요
그런데
새를 25%로 올리셨대요
[음악]
제가 오늘은
굉장히 좀 특별한 게스트분을 모셨는데
진짜 우리나라에 처음 그 홈스타일
리스트를 만드신 분입니다
페이스홈 한혜원 대표님 모셨습니다
안녕하세요
안녕하세요 저는 대표 한혜원입니다
근데 제가 만든 것까지는 아니고
자격증 반응 만들었는데요
홈스타일링이라는 단어는 사실 누가
만들었는지
분명하지가 않더라구요
근데 저는 이제 홈스타일링을 알리고
싶은 사람 중에 한 명입니다
스타일링이 뭔지 좀 한번 설명 좀 해
주시겠어요 오히려 대표님한테 한번
여쭤보고 싶어요 홈스타일링은 어떤
거라고 생각을 하셨어요
저는 가정 연출가
원래 미국이나 이런
데는 이렇게 가정 연출가 그런
분들이랑 같이 주택을 보러 다녀요
집을 팔 때 무조건 인테리어를 하고
팔거든 좀 한번 좀 정확히 좀
알려주세요
먼저 홈스타일링이라는 거는
인테리어와 차이가 무엇인지를 많이
물어보시더라고요
그리고 소품 등을 이용해서 공간을 좀
풍성하게
완성을 시키는 건데요 여러분들이 쉽게
생각하시려면 모델하우스를 떠올리시면
되세요 그래서 집을 모델하우스처럼
이렇게 완벽하게 세팅해주는 일을
홈스타일링이라고 생각을 해주시면
됩니다 보통 사람들이 그렇잖아요 우리
집 인테리어에 엄마 집 인테리어 한대
이런 인테리어는
리모델링 개념이거든요 근데
홈스타일링은
그렇게 막 많이 마감재를 손대지 않고
그냥 가구나 뭐 이런 것들로
완성을 하는 거예요가 사용할 수 있는
것들로 완성한다 이렇게 생각하시면 될
것 같아요 이거 수강생도 모집해가지고
또 하시고
하는데 저는 앞으로이 직업이 되게 좀
더
성장할 것 같거든요 많은 분들이고
어찌됐든 많이 알려지면 이거를
직업으로 삼는 분들이 더 많아질 것
같고 그리고 이게 또 부동산이랑
접목될게 너무 많아요 집 인테리어도
안 하고 가구도 사실 다 빼고
팔거든요
완전 황하게
맞아요 그래서 제가 집 보여줘도 거의
한
5분만에 그냥 보여주는 것도 끝나고
막 그러는데
근데 뭔가 이렇게 인테리어도 돼 있고
가구도 또 이렇게
쇼룸처럼 배치가 돼 있으면
뭔가 나중에 매각하거나
임대할 때도 너무 좀 도움이 많이 될
것 같아요 그래서 좀 앞으로이 직업이
저는 되게 전망이 좋다고 생각을
합니다 집을 꾸밀 때
인테리어가 리모델링을 다 해놓고 있는
가구를 가지고 왔을 때 만족하는
경우들이 좀 드무시더라구요 이런
경우에 이제 스타 더해진다고 하거든요
그렇게 됐을 때 뭔가 공간에 완성도가
높기 때문에
점점 그런 가구의 가치를 알아보시는
분들이 많아지셨어요
옛날에 비해서 예전에는 그냥 쇼파
앉으면 되는 거지
약간 의자 앉으면 되는 거지 약간
이렇게 생각을 하셨다면 이제는 정말
디자인 가구에 대해서 계속 그 가치를
아시는 분들이 많아지고 그리고 이제
가구들이 어떻게 배치됐을 때 예쁜지
이런 거에 관심을 가지시는 분들이
제가 전에 그게 약간 코로나19
덕분이 아닐까
엄청 많아졌어요 오히려
어떤 가구들은 되팔 때 더 비싼
가구도 있어요네 이렇게 가치를 알고
구매를 하시면 그런게 좋은 거 같고요
뭐라고 해야죠 삶의 질을 높이는 그런
것들이 사람들이 그런 것들에 관심을
갖게 됐다이 가정 안에서 되게
편안함을 느끼는 요소들이 많아진 거죠
예전에는 잠만 자면 되는
직업이 좋지 않을까 이게 일반
고객들에게도 클라이언트 분들에게도 더
뭔가 적은 예산으로 공간이 더 예뻐질
수 있는 거니까 좀 이따 인테리어
한게 좀 준비한게 있는데 보안을 좀
같이 보도록 하겠습니다
원래 이제 전에
완전
옛날네 제가 이제이 사무실을 보러
왔을 때의 모습이에요 찍어 놓은게
있더라고요 여기가 약간 상담하시는
곳이었대요 여기서 상담을 아이들
그러니까
청소년 아동 이런 아이들을 상담하는
장소였다고 하더라고요
저희는 이제 지금 수업을 또
사무실에서 수업도 하고 있거든요
그래서 그런 공간으로 바뀌면서 같은
공간인데 사실 공사는 많이 하지
않았어요 공사는이 카페트를 열어보니까
원래 이제 타일로 이렇게 되어
있더라구요 전 나쁘지 않아서 바닥은
그대로 뒀고요 그래서 그냥 페인트하고
조명요
정도
필름지 정도만 시공을 한 거예요네
그래서 제가 커튼이랑 블라인드 하고
그 다음에 이제 조명계획한 다음에
이제 가구만 바뀌었는데 좀 다른
공간이 된 거 같아요 완전 달라져요네
실제 가면 좀 더 아늑한 느낌 조명
때문에 사실 많이 공사한게 없거든요
그래서 이제 톤을 그냥 하나로
일관되게 바꾸고 그 다음에 이제
조명이 매일 조명이었는데이 공간이
크지가 않아요
그러다 보니까 그 내려와 있는 조명이
더 좁게 느껴지더라고요 그래서 매입
조명으로 바꾸고 그리고 이제 그냥
가구를 심플하게 이제 배치를 했어요
비용이 제일 많이 들어간게 어떤
거예요 여기서는 사실
페인트 비용이 좀 들어갔고 많이
들어가는게 없어요 아 그리고 이거
수납장을 만드는게 이제 수납이 너무
부족했어요
그런데 이제 여기 화장실 문이 되게
너무 안 예쁘더라고요 그래서 그냥
장 계획을 이렇게 짜면서이 문을
닫으면 화장실 문이 안 보이는 거예요
그래서 아래 사진도 보시면 이렇게 다
닫으면 그냥 장처럼
근데 그래서 화장실이 없는 줄 알고
계셔서 좋기도 해요 화장실
문을 감추고 그 옆에도 도어거든요
그래서 그 아까 안 예뻤던 보일러실도
그냥 하나로 다 가구처럼 마감을
했어요 거울도 이쁜 거 같아요
그래서 거울을 이제 이렇게 가리려고
최소한의 비용으로 좀 예뻐 보이게
하는 방법을
찾는 편인 것 같아요 이거를 막 다
부셔서 다시 할 순 없으니까
네 근데
화장실인데이 지금 천장도 되게 이게
한 번도
완전 실제로 봤을 때는 정말 좀
으시시할 정도로
그랬거든요이 바닥에 있는 타일이
외벽 타일이에요 외벽 그 건물 외벽에
썼던 타일을
바닥재
타일로 재사용을
했더라고요네 여기
파란 타일이 외벽에 썼던 타일이에요
그래서 이게
지어진지가 아마 2 30년 된 거
같은데 그대로 이렇게 한
명도 고치신 분이 없이 이렇게
임대를 다 쓰고
계시더라고요네 그래서 이제 타일
상태도 너무 안 좋고 해서 저는 이제
이렇게는 못 쓰니까 여기는 그냥
아이봉사를 한 거예요 그래서 천장이랑
모든게 다 바뀐 거죠
진짜 깔끔하잖아요 이게 디자인이
더해지면
금액이 올라가니까 사실 그냥 600각
타일로 깨끗하게 가성비 있게
그렇게 바꿨어요
요거 많이 쓰잖아요
여기서 사진 찍고 여기 뒤에 조명
되게 괜찮은 거 같아요
저는 아늑한 느낌을 주는 거 같아요
야 그러세요 근데 사실 세면대가
밑으로 배수가 되어 있어서
벽빛으로 바꾸려고
하면 좀 일이 비용이 더 드니까
그래서 요거를 그대로 바닥 배수를
어떻게 쓰지 하다가 이제 세면대를
찾게 된 거예요
비용을
[음악]
절약하기 위해서
화장실에 외벽타일을 쓰셨다고 하는데
그것도 저는 너무
재밌는 거예요네
거의 완전
새 건물처럼 된 거예요네 그래서
건물주분이 너무 좋아하셨어요 와보시고
근데 좀 불안해요 새를 올리시진
않겠죠
그래서 나중에
막 사무실 임대하거나 할 때도 저는
화장실이 제일 중요해요
물론 이제 사무실 공간도 중요하긴
하지만 이게 화장실에 어떠냐에 따라서
여직원이 채용이 되냐 안 되냐
맞아요
저는 화장실을 되게 좀 신경 많이
쓰라고 하는 편인데 그래서 만약에
제가 사무실인데 알아보러 갔는데
화장실이 이거다라고 하면 진짜 인대
안 나가요 만약에 지금 뭐 임대 중인
건물 있으시면 좀 이렇게 화장실에
조금 신경을 써 보는 거를 저는 되게
추천을 합니다
정말 욕실이 지금 타일도 요즘엔 너무
다양하기 때문에
생각보다 비싼 타일 안 골라도
임대운 얼마든지 할 수 있으니까
그렇게 해서 바꾸시면 정말 확실히
달라지실 것 같아요 일단 남자 여자
같이 쓰는 화장실은 최악이에요 그거는
절대 하면 안 되고 일단 최대한
나눠야 되고 그리고
기본적으로 이게 다 돼 있긴 해야
돼요 저희 이제 호텔 가도 화장실
때문에 이제 그 호텔에 대한 이미지가
좀 개인적인 생각인데
정말이에요
화장실은 좀 신경을 많이
써야 되는 부분 중에 하는 것
같습니다
쇼핑몰도 마찬가지고 음식점도
그렇잖아요 말씀하셨듯이 남녀공용 있는
곳보다는 따로 되어 있는 데를 더
선호하게 되는 거 같아요네
건물주분께서 그 뒤에 또 궁금해
하셨던
완전 최저
금액으로 사무실을 바꿔 드렸다고
했잖아요 아래층 저랑 같은 구조인데
새가 너무 안 나가신다고
도움을 청하셨어요
그래가지고 거기는 그냥 해드리진
않았고
업체를 소개해 가지고 그냥 페인트하고
전기로만 전기공사로만 이제 해드렸던
공간도 보내 드렸거든요
그 말씀 해주셨던 새가 한 달 넘게
안 나가던
곳이었어요 너무 어디 계속
천장도 블랙이에요 이렇게 그 세입자
분이 해놓고 나가시고 나서이 주인분이
보신 거죠 그랬는데 이제 조명도 너무
일단 부족했고
고장난 것도 있었고 그 다음에
전체적으로 딱 들어갔을 때 나라도
임대하기 힘들겠다 약간 이런 생각을
했거든요 그래서 일단은 좀 좁은
공간이니까
약간 밝게 바꾸자 해서
조금 따뜻한 화이트로 컬러를 그냥
통일을 했고요 그리고 이제 조명이
너무 부족했으니까 내일 조명을 떼고
이제 매입 조명으로 바꿔서 좋은
계획을 했고네 그리고 바닥은 그대로
살렸는데 다 밝아지고 나니까 그렇게
나쁘지가 않더라고요
[웃음]
그러니까요 근데 또 그런가 봐요 좀
생각이 다르잖아요 건물주 국내 어쨌든
최소 금액으로 하고 싶으셨으니까
근데 이렇게 바꾸는데
200만원이 채 안 들었거든요
그런데
새를 25%로 올리셨대요 비포어
사진을 올렸을 때는 정말 한 달 동안
아예 보러 오시는 분이 없었대요
부동산에 올려놔도 저한테도 안 볼 것
같아요
이게 생각보다 이렇게 돼 있는
건물들이 너무 많아요
버려져 있는 건물
신경 안 쓰는 건물 그런게 되게
많은데
진짜 조금만 신경 써도
임대료도 조금 더 높게 받을 수도
있고
임대도 되게 빨리 맞출 수 있어서
일단 밝아야 돼요 제가 봤을 때
좁은 공간은 좀 밝아야 될 거 같아요
사람들이 되게 많이 보러 오시는구나
이걸 저도 이제 이걸 해드리면서
알았어요
어 그리고 이제 집이네요 아네 그래서
사실 이거는 제가 방송용으로 보내드린
건 아니고 약간 이제 대표님이 궁금해
하시길래
뭔지
참고용으로 같이 보내 드리긴 한
건데요